so these are some of my favorite kids my
godson is the one with the Rubik's Cube
my niece and nephew there and so around
2050 these kids will be in their 30s
which if you have kids that you know
this will be true of them also so when
I'm like you through some of what's
projected for the earth system around
2050 and and this isn't primarily based
on climate model predictions like we
used to this is looking at striations of
what's happening to the system now and
this tends to come from scientists and
researchers that are looking at
different parts of the system
individually and so firstly we have a
projection that the amount of forest
burn area in the United States will be
10 times what it was in 1970 so today
it's about three times what it was in
1970 and so it's tracking along with
temperature rise so two or three decades
from now we can anticipate lots more
forest fires than we have today
alongside that going on at the same time
will have the effects of heat on the
ocean and the one that we hear a lot
about is a heat effect on coral reefs
coral reefs support 25% of life in the
ocean and currently they're being killed
by heat stress they're sensitive to heat
big heat waves are coming we've lost
somewhere between a quarter and a half
of the coral reefs in the world already
and they support a big portion of ocean
life so we don't know yet quite what
happens when we lose that life and the
ocean is a really complex highly
interconnected system and so heat stress
on the ocean could have effects that we
can't fully predict in terms of what
happens to other life in the ocean and
the links between the ocean in the
atmosphere so there's a form of life
that grows at the surf and surface of
the ocean called phytoplankton and that
biological life is quite important to
feeding the fish below and it also
handles interaction between the ocean in
the atmosphere I call it the API layer
between the ocean in the atmosphere so
it takes in co2 free that's sort of
interprets what's happening the ocean
it's produced by the the ocean food web
and then it interacts with
miss fira takes in co2 it releases gases
that help form clouds and it's very
important to our system currently
phytoplankton we're losing at a rate
about one percent a year or sorry a
decade and it's thought that in the past
few since 1950 we may have lost as much
as 40 percent of the phytoplankton on
the ocean so we have to watch for things
like this in terms of the whole system
another thing we have to watch for is
collapse of ice sheets in Antarctica
this is a picture by Chris Michael Chris
where are you who has many wonderful
Antarctic pictures there and and can
talk to you about what it's like to go
to Antarctica many times and so if if
those ice sheets were to collapse as
they are predicted when temperatures
approach around 1.9 degrees then we
might see some big changes some big
abrupt changes in sea level in sea level
rise and in the nature of the current
circulation in the ocean and the major a
mock current so again these kinds of
things are predicted to happen around
1.9 degrees and as we saw in a previous
chart we're looking at that around the
middle of this century based on what's
happening and again concurrent with
those things we have effects on
infrastructure so one of the things to
think about when we think about climate
change
especially when it comes to discussion
of adaptation is we're likely to have
lots of things going on at once and a
lot of our infrastructure was built to a
certain range of conditions of
temperature of wind a storm surge of
ground conditions and we're starting to
push the climate outside of the
conditions that some of that
infrastructure was built for so these
are two charts the chart on the Left
shows the vulnerability of bridges in
the United States and it's forecast that
by 2050 about half the bridges in the
United States will be vulnerable meaning
they need reengineering half the bridge
in the United States and the other chart
is looking at the vulnerability of
coastal military infrastructure which is
something that the military takes pretty
seriously and you can see an enormous
amount of vulnerability to flooding of
that infrastructure making possibly
rendering some of some of those sites
unviable so and those are just a couple
of examples and I'm I'm not here to
necessarily raise alarms but what I want
to do is say can we think rationally and
logically about the set of conditions
that we're facing and the kinds of
options that we might need to look at
because heat stress is something that
creates a number of big changes and big
challenges concurrently that could lead
to a lot of suffering for people and a
lot of your reversible changes in our
natural systems good news
we're in Silicon Valley and I'm lucky
because I know the head of research at
the slack and lots of people in venture
capital and people at Stanford at the
Precourt Institute and Berkeley where
they're working on energy solutions and
the things that are coming in the
pipeline in terms of energy materials
capturing carbon are extraordinary I'm a
techno optimist and I believe that by
the end of the century it's absolutely
possible that we could have solutions to
waste to energy to food production that
allow the sustainable sustainable
healthy happy life for people on this
planet for years to come and big natural
systems that sustain themselves too so
the question is how does that look in
terms of kind of the timeline to our
solutions and so this is a chart that's
based on IPCC information and the United
Nations environmental program showing
what we would have to do to maintain
temperature below two degrees with the
tools that we have at our disposal today
so based on emissions reduction alone we
would need to start moving to zero
emissions by 2030
which is 12 years from now in order to
stay below 2 degrees zero emissions zero
net emissions by 2030
so that doesn't look very likely based
on what it takes to transition energy
production and other things so then we
introduced in the IPCC has introduced
the notion of removing carbon from the
atmosphere so actively finding
mechanisms that can filter the air bring
down carbon finding more ways to
actively plant organic material trees
and other things that will pull carbon
out of the air actively and so what
they've done in IPCC projections as
they've said if we have these things
then it is possible to extend the time
that we have to safely stay under 2
degrees but you'll notice from the chart
that these requires starting to
implement these negative emissions
technologies now and and scaling them up
very rapidly and the folks in and around
the IPCC will will admit that these
things do not exist yet and they haven't
they haven't been fully analyzed even
the notion of planting trees more
aggressively in a in a certain type of
way in order to increase their our co2
absorption so we have a challenge that
we have a pipeline of capabilities that
in the future could lead to a zero
emissions world and a way that we can
reclaim greenhouse gases from the air
but we don't have them today typically
it takes about 50 years to transform
infrastructure and replace it so we have
some period of time between today and
the future where we have you know a
disruptive set of technologies that we
need we're right in the middle of that
that time span that we talked about
around the middle of this century 2050
we have a bit of a problem because
that's when big system changes might
occur that create a lot of suffering for
people and potentially set off
reactions that we can't control
[Music]
you